en el último vídeo pudimos visualizar
una molécula de etano con una proyección
de newman y lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es mostrarte que en realidad
podemos visualizar cadenas mucho más
largas o incluso como veremos en vídeos
posteriores podemos dibujar estructuras
cíclicas o moléculas basadas en anillos
de carbono con estas proyecciones de
newman y y supongo que la siguiente
molécula digamos más compleja que
podemos estudiar sería el butano en
realidad podríamos empezar con el
propano pero el butano nos va a hacer un
muy buen ejemplo aunque entonces vamos a
pintar la molécula del butano y antes de
comenzar con la proyección de newman
creo que repasemos un poco cómo son los
modelos de esferas y barras entonces
para el butano pues tenemos que dibujar
nuestra cadena de carbono es verdad
tenemos nuestra cadena de 4 carbonos ahí
lo tienen son 4 carbonos y en cada uno
de estos pues hay que rellenar los
espacios necesarios con hidrógeno es
verdad para este primero necesitamos 3
hidrógenos para el segundo necesitamos
dos hidrógenos lo mismo necesitamos para
el segundo para el tercero perdón
necesitamos otros dos hidrógenos y el
último necesita otros tres hidrógenos
muy bien entonces ya que tenemos esto
necesitamos pensar bueno cuál de estos
cuatro carbonos van a va a ser el que va
a ir al frente y cuál va a ir atrás
entonces si los enumeramos podríamos
elegir este de aquí el segundo el que va
a ir al frente éste irá al frente
mientras que este que voy a marcar con
azul irá atrás muy bien entonces antes
de comenzar con el digamos con el dibujo
de la proyección de newman de esta
molécula lo que quiero hacer es hacer un
modelo modificado de de esferas y barras
muy bien entonces como lo voy a hacer
este carbono que voy a poner al frente
justo ya está con rojo vamos a pintarlo
aquí este es nuestro carbono y este está
unido al carbono de atrás verdad que
para que se vea más claro que va atrás
vamos a ponerlo
así muy bien entonces ahí tenemos
digamos nuestra estructura base y aquí
tenemos estos dos hidrógenos verdad
tenemos estos dos hidrógenos los cuales
vamos a poner aquí con todo y sus
bolitas para que se vea claro que son
esferas mientras que ahora ponemos estos
dos hidrógenos tenemos estos dos
hidrógenos ahí los tienen y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer para modificar este modelo
es considerar a todo este grupo este s
h3 como una sola digamos con una sola
esfera verdad entonces vamos a unir esto
con un ch 3 que pues tiene que ser muy
grande porque no sólo tiene un átomo
verdad tiene cuatro átomos y vamos a
considerar de la misma forma este grupo
de atrás que digamos podríamos pensar
que es un grupo metilo verdad entonces
podemos poner todo este grupo aquí atrás
también con una esfera muy grande
entonces ya que tenemos este modelo
modificado esto nos va a servir mucho
para dibujar nuestra proyección de
newman
entonces como ya como ya hemos visto
ponemos nuestra nuestro carbono del
frente que va a ser este rojo y este
está unido a nuestros dos hidrógenos
verdad de esta forma más o menos estoy
tratando de representar como se ve aquí
ahora bien aquí abajo está unido a un
grupo ch3 y lo voy a poner completo como
si fuera una sola digamos estructura muy
bien ahora vamos a poner nuestro carbono
del fondo aquí tenemos nuestro carbono
del fondo y si sigo digamos como está
dibujado aquí en este modelo de velas y
barras modificado pues entonces arriba
se encuentra el ch 3 verdad y digamos a
los costados y abajo se encuentran
nuestros hidrógenos restantes muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos la una proyección
de newman que que nos sirve para
identificar esta molécula de butano
entonces como puedes darte cuenta aquí
digamos lo pintamos de una forma digamos
alternada esta fue una forma alternada
pero como vimos en el vídeo anterior en
realidad puede haber muchísimas con
formaciones en las que esta misma
molécula se puede representar y todas
tienen características muy distintas por
ejemplo esta de aquí que acabamos de
pintar se le conoce como la conformación
anti ok es la conformación anti y en
realidad ésta resulta ser la más estable
porque recordemos que cada uno de estos
átomos pues tiene nubes de electrones
alrededor moviéndose y demás pero lo que
distingue a esta molécula en particular
o digamos más bien en este diagrama es
que tenemos considerando aquí grupos ch3
y los grupos de h3 puedes pensar que en
realidad son de los más importantes
cuando estamos pensando en la energía
potencial que tienen estas moléculas
porque contienen nubes de electrones
mucho más grandes porque no sólo tienen
al carbono sino además otros tres
hidrógenos cada uno entonces a la hora
de determinar digamos o intuir cómo es
la energía potencial los
más grandes tienen digamos mayor peso a
la hora de ser considerados verdad y si
te das cuenta en esta conformación
tenemos la el ángulo más grande posible
entre estos dos grupos ch3 este es un
ángulo de 180 grados en su ángulo yedro
verdad que ya platicamos un poco de él
en el vídeo anterior entonces su ángulo
diedro es de 180 grados que es el máximo
ángulo que podemos encontrar quiere
decir que esto va a ser digamos la
conformación más estable porque tiene
una energía potencial más baja una
energía potencial más baja y si a lo
mejor no no no te queda muy claro qué es
eso de la energía potencial puedes
pensar por ejemplo en una piedra que
está reposando sobre el suelo verdad esa
esa piedra tiene una energía potencial
muy baja y eso hace que esté en un
estado digamos de reposo que esté que se
estable si por ejemplo consideras esa
piedra a tres metros de altura tiene una
energía potencial mucho más alta
y eso hace que sea inestable porque por
ejemplo si tú sueltas esa piedra pues
inmediatamente va a moverse y va a
moverse y va a tender al estado digamos
que se encuentra en el suelo que es
justo la energía potencial el estado con
energía potencial más baja verdad
entonces justamente como con esta
analogía podemos decir que esta es la
conformación más estable muy bien
ahora bien vamos a utilizar las
proyecciones de newman para ver qué
otras posibles con formaciones podemos
encontrar entonces vamos a pintar aquí
nuestro primer carbono que está unido
con sus dos hidrógenos verdad y por acá
abajo está unido al ch 3 en nuestro
grupo
ch 3 y vamos a pintar de una vez también
nuestro segundo átomo de carbono
y déjenme de una vez copio esto porque
vamos a ver al menos unas 3 con
formaciones distintas ok vamos a copiar
y pegar ok vamos a ver 3 con formaciones
distintas muy bien vamos a pegar otro
y ahí está vamos a estudiar que es
distintas conformaciones podemos poner y
la primera de ellas corresponde por
ejemplo qué pasaría si éste si este
hidrógeno de aquí lo giramos 120 grados
entonces si lo giramos 120 grados toman
el lugar del ch 3 entonces queda acá
arriba este hidrógeno entonces éste este
otro hidrógeno pues también gira 120
grados y quedaría de este lado y
finalmente tendríamos nuestro ch3
quedaría aquí en nuestro ch3 porque está
unido a la molécula de atrás verdad
entonces nuevamente esta es una
conformación alternada pero lo que
tienen es que estos ch3 ya no están tan
separados como en el caso anterior
verdad tienen cierta cierta proximidad y
aunque éste este digamos esta
conformación no es no es la más estable
tampoco es inestable verdad no es tan
inestable es como un punto medio y
justamente a esta conformación se le
conoce como la conformación de ghanuchi
formación de caucho muy bien es la
conformación de ghanuchi ahora bien como
dijimos esta tiene una energía potencial
que no es del todo baja ni tampoco muy
alta verdad está como en el punto medio
vamos a ver qué pasa por ejemplo si
rotamos 60 grados en directo en la
dirección de las manecillas del reloj
verdad si nosotros rotamos quiere decir
que éste ch3 quedaría justo eclipsado
por el otro ch3 entonces
tenemos algo así y por ejemplo este
hidrógeno también queda eclipsado con
este otro hidrógeno y el otro también
verdad entonces justo esta es una
conformación eclipsada y tiene una
energía potencial potencial muy alta
verdad estos estos dos grupos de sh 3
están muy cerca y eso hace que se
empiecen a repeler por sus nubes de
electrones verdad que están muy cerca
entonces esta es la menos estable que es
la menos estable de todas las
conformaciones posibles ahora bien qué
pasa si volvemos a rotar por ejemplo
ahora quedaría nuestro ch3 de este otro
lado verdad ahí quedaría nuestro ch3 y
nuestros otros hidrógenos pues podrían
quedar justamente de este lado y esta
también es una conformación de ghanuchi
y como vimos en el caso anterior pues no
están estables ni tampoco tan inestable
verdad es como el punto medio entonces
estas son las posibles con formaciones
que podemos encontrar con las
proyecciones de d
de newman así que espero que realmente
hayas entendido cómo es que al elegir
nuestros dos primeros carbonos iniciales
uno que va a ir al frente y otro va a ir
atrás y al poner todas las cosas que
están unidas a esos carbonos podemos
representarlos como grupos completos y
verdad como nuestro ch3 y cuando hacemos
eso es decir cuando utilizamos esta
proyección de newman para cualquier
parte de una molécula cuando cuando
hacemos eso podremos empezar a pensar
cómo rotarlo para que estas partes
queden de alguna conformación particular
o no se podremos ver todas las
conformaciones posibles es decir
podríamos ver todas las versiones
posibles de esta molécula junto con o al
menos podremos intuir cómo se comporta
respecto a su energía potencial y su
estabilidad